i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies and tv uh
for each of you what do you think might
surprise fans to learn about the actual
making of discovery
i think
i think one of the things that that's
what's most surprising to me is just how
enormous and immersive our sets are that
you you really can suspend disbelief and
get lost in there and now that we're
using this new ar wall technology it's
even more so so it's it's a great
uh set for for an actor right you could
just
disappear into it
that's what i was gonna say
but that's why i went first
i think i think do i do believe most
people would imagine you know there's so
much cgi and so many things that yes
they're when you when we're looking at
the view screen of the bridge that's you
know we're looking at a green screen
because then they fill it in later but
everything that's on the bridge is you
can touch and see
the only time that's not the case if we
have a hologram everything else is so
there for us it's tactile and that's i
think
rare may surprise people
yeah it's you you said get lost i but i
do like get lost on our ship which is
like crazy to be able to say
four years later i still need somebody
to guide me around yeah
wow
can i do a follow-up i'm curious what
this ar thing that you mentioned is
can you describe that because i'm not
sure if i'm familiar with this so it's a
technology they used in the mandalorian
so that's
yeah
it's that
it's an led screen that covers about
260 degrees yeah it looks kind of like
if you were looking at it from above it
would look like an upside down u yeah
ish and so there's a set built in the
middle of that space and on all the wall
around it is is floor to ceiling images
and it and it's the the what really
makes it effective for this purpose and
it gets really techno but
the if the camera is looking at this
part of the wall this image of the wall
then is extra augmented extra high def
and then it also alters its depth and
moves with the camera as the camera is
moving so it's incredibly responsive so
it just always is appropriate so it
doesn't look just like a painted
backdrop sure if you're not careful you
will get some motion sickness
if you look at the screen and it starts
moving in a weird way but you definitely
but it lets you be on another planet and
really look like you're looking at the
horizon of that planet right instead of
looking at a tennis ball and say oh
there's a planet over here you can
actually see it yeah it's the volume
technology that mandalorian is using it
it's it it's amazing because i think
that it really opens if you're using the
technology it really opens the door on
what you can do this season that maybe
you couldn't do in previous seasons yeah
and our ar wall is sub i'm not to brag
but our wall is substantially
substantially larger than any other wall
our wall is better right
so one of the things that i think that
the trailer uh
touches on and from and this is what i'm
gathering from the footage i've seen is
that this season is about you guys
having to overcome like a science
problem it's not like a villain it's you
guys trying to work together the galaxy
coming together to solve a problem and
uh i guess what can you tease about
season four and am i right about this
you're right about that i think it's in
a way it's it's our writers taking
what's been going on in our world which
is the science problem that happened out
of nowhere that felt random that felt uh
you know
extreme that had this an incredible
damaging force and every all these
scientists around our world had to come
together to try to solve it that's very
much what season four is also about and
the part of part of
this particular problem that we're
dealing with in season four is also it's
incredibly unpredictable and chaotic
um so it's not yeah it doesn't have like
a malevolent force
as in a villain
you know pointing a finger at a at a
planet and saying you are doomed it's
just this thing that's happening that's
causing so much chaos and destruction um
that you know that requires people to
come together i also think what's great
about it and the parallels that i
appreciate from the season
to our real life is that because it's
science and it's something that we've
never seen before for instance like a
new virus that's never been seen before
there that when there's new science
we have to be agile enough to respond to
new circumstances and perhaps change the
way that we deal with it because we have
new information but that's how science
works you know you're not something that
may that was true yesterday
may not we may find out is different
tomorrow and so we need to be able to
adjust in that way and so um i think
that's a great lesson that that's taught
uh this season as well
i really wonder it's making me think i
wonder what the percentage of star trek
viewers that are vaccinated is
because
you know i'll bet you it's real high
i hope so yeah you know just all of our
mistakes
yeah it's just a completely random thing
that i just realized you know people
anyway um i gotta stop and i'm just
gonna say again congrats i can't wait to
watch the season um and blue i think you
talked a little too much i need you to
take it down next time
thank you so much for your time
seriously thank you very much